right now
right now at this moment the u.s media
are in a complete and total crisis
but it's one that they don't seem to
fully grasp now to help you understand
how we got here i want to take a
specific look
at how certain anchors responded to
trump's inaugural versus how they
responded
to biden's inaugural let's start with
msnbc's
larry o'donnell the trump tv series has
a title
american carnage there has never been
a first day president of the united
states
with more experience more knowledge
groveling and ahistorical
well here's his compatriot rachel maddow
i just didn't hear very much of donald
trump in the speech i thought it was
marshall i thought it was dark
i don't know exactly what the line will
be that we remember forever i think the
one that is sticking with me is
we must end this uncivil war
but don't worry rachel i'm sure biden
won't remember his speech either
but those are opinion hosts so fawning
is expected what about the news anchors
here's cnn's jake tapper
i think it's fair to say this is one of
the most radical
inaugural speeches we've ever heard we
saw the steely determination
and compassion of president joe biden
now was it was it really compassion when
he called half the country
racist or nativist here's cnn's dana
bash
no lofty rhetoric here that that was not
what this is about
his speech was so sincere
uh and that sincerity matched the times
and matched the moment
now how much will sincerity raise
middle-class wages well i think we know
the answer on that
finally here's cnn's john king
it was a dark a dark view even a
pessimistic view
of where we are at the moment the giant
challenge with the country so divided
with the congress so evenly divided
but what a powerful beginning
well perhaps sensing all the fawning
would open her
peers up to criticism washington post
media columnist
margaret sullivan issued this warning
the media can be glad
for the biden white house's return to
normalcy but
let's not be lulled except when you read
beyond the headline
her real intention becomes obvious
there's a difference between truly
holding power to account
and grandstanding it's the latter that
gave rise to ridiculous dustups like the
one over president obama's
wearing of a tan suit and shameful
overplaying of the hillary clinton email
scandal during the 2016 campaign
in other words don't actually go hard on
old joe
ever especially when it could cost him
politically so
it should come as no surprise that trust
in traditional media
is at an all-time low according to
edelman's annual trust barometer 56
percent of americans agree
that journalists and reporters are
purposely trying to mislead people
by saying things they know are false or
gross exaggerations
joining me now is glenn greenwald
pulitzer prize winning journalist and
author glenn um do you expect this
to change at all as briden's presidency
continues no i expect it to get
significantly worse and i have to say
laura you really know how to rile up a
guest forcing me to listen to those
hideous grotesque videos in my ear one
after the next
right before i'm ready to speak that was
actually quite disgusting
the reason that this is happening and
this is a trend that has
been going on for quite some time and
it's not like these journalists don't
talk about it or don't know it they
actually talk about it quite a bit but
when they talk about it the fact that
they're losing faith and trust
on the part of the public they do one of
three things either they complain about
it and whine about it like it's so
unfair because they're entitled to
deference
or they blame their critics they say the
reason this is happening is because
people point out our errors and point
out that we're engaged in propaganda and
not reporting so it's their fault
and now what they're doing is they're
trying to just censor everybody
off of the internet so you essentially
have no choice but to listen to the
people
that these polls show are no longer
trustworthy and i think what everyone is
going to see is exactly what that
video montage demonstrated which is
people will remember
how they conducted themselves during the
trump administration
and they will see the glaring difference
not when there's a difference between
the two presidents
but when they're the same they will
treat them wildly differently and that
reaction that
lack of trust will continue to worsen
undoubtedly
and glenn i want to move forward to uh
what i know you're interested in a topic
of the
militarization of the capital
uh with the concern that there were
going to be marauding bands of
hundreds or thousands of of angry
americans who were threatening congress
and the inauguration
we found out tonight that our national
guard troops are
now sleeping in a garage because they
were kicked out of the capitol
do you have any doubt that they were
treated like like props political props
to to get this whole militarization
going and scare the people
well so you know the argument can be
made well the only reason why there
wasn't an attack on the inauguration is
precisely because we militarized
but what about the states the capitals
of each state
there there was no massive
militarization and you heard a week ago
10 days ago
leaks from the fbi through abc news and
others claiming in order to scare people
as much as possible
that there were going to be enormous
numbers of insurrectionary insurgents or
domestic terrorists which is what
they're calling republicans now
is essentially attending to assault
state capitals if they couldn't
get into washington and there was a
grand total of one
anti-biden protester both at the capitol
in albany and new york and the one
in california
they're constantly now body riled up
because no one's going to pay attention
if all you're doing is talking about joe
biden they want people scared
and nervous and acquiescent to the
ruling class and that's why they're
kind of spinning these these stories
your pal
paul krugman of the new york times
tweeted this out today
so what happened to the insurrection
maybe i'm jinxing it but the wave of
violence many expected didn't
materialize
before or on inauguration day there were
hardly any demonstrators
where did all the rage go well glenn
krugman's trying to mock trump
supporters but
i i don't think he realized what he was
actually doing that
either the threat the supposed threat of
mass uprisings
wasn't a real threat or that it was
exaggerated by an intelligence
apparatus that has been known to
exaggerate other threats
for other ulterior motives
laura they the the entire goal of the
democratic party from
starting with joe biden and this isn't
me saying this the wall street journal
and others have reported it
is to institute a new war on terror bill
that's modeled after the first war on
terror that was directed outward at
foreign actors and
foreign governments but to bring all of
those powers inward adam schiff has a
bill pending since 2019
that they want to now use a pretext for
which is that america is on the verge of
civil war there's roving bands of
insurgents
this is all designed to entrench powers
in their hands that we would never
otherwise agree that they should have
to surveil people to monitor people to
infiltrate groups to break up
protest to criminalize speech and we
have to be extremely vigilant
about the role the media is playing in
that if the other was called the patriot
act which was a total disaster
what will this be called this will be
called the real patriot act we're
serious now glenn
thanks so much great to see you tonight
thank you and ken stars